hey roger hey martin what's up
oh nothing much uh i see you still have
uh dog photos on the wall behind you
you're still doing dog photography
i still do and that reminds me last time
we spoke
we did a rest api with a firestore back
end
but a lot of comments have come in
asking us to do the same rest api
but with a cloud sql backend what do you
think about that
oh that sounds fun let's do it let's do
it
[Music]
all right so i created a barkbark api
project here
and i guess now we need to create a
cloud sql instance huh
yep and that shouldn't be too hard it's
pretty simple they make it pretty simple
there's a few clicks yeah
should we do my sequel for sure yep
sounds good to me
let's do it
all right and here
about uh instance id
bark bark and
for a password i will enter
my super secret password here visible
for everybody
yep let's keep this between us yeah
that's right
uh iowa and uh
sequel uh 5.7 looks good
all right uh let's see uh
maybe for this bark bark api we don't
need four cpus
yeah not yet uh for development purposes
let's shrink that down
to something a little bit smaller yeah
that's right
a little bit smaller and a little bit
cheaper so one cpu i'm sure will be fine
all right and let's hit create this
would be a good time to go and
refill that coffee cup yep i'm gonna go
walk my dog so i'll be back
all right and we're so we're back the
database has been created the database
server instance has been created
what's next now we have to actually
create a database
for our data to live oh right
because one database server can have
many database instances
in databases on it right yes
so maybe dog data should we call it that
let's name it dog data and this should
only take a
quick second there it is it's done nice
uh
so now we have an empty database no
tables or anything so
let's connect to it via the cloud
console
yeah now we're in all right cool
so here we're in the database uh let's
see if we have any tables
oh we need to pick a database
so we'll use this database okay so we're
in dog data database
let's see what tables we have oh no
tables
none so now let's create a table
called breeds breeds okay that sounds
good
and this is going to have the same uh
fields that we did in our last video so
it's going to have a
name field okay varchar 30.
make that unique that way we can use so
we don't have more than one
uh breed in there of the same name life
expectancy
i've expected expectancy
yep sudden int
that is an instant okay and what is it
more
type right ah we should have had type
before life expectancy
oh was typed before yeah let's do that
very good that means i have to spell
life expectancy
again that's a hard word yes you do and
then was it origin right
origin that's another varchar
all right so
we now have a table alright let's see
what's in the table
there should be absolutely nothing in
that table so
last video you mentioned you like
poodles so let's add poodle
to our sql database okay
insert into breeds values
uh don't forget the values keyword or
else it's going to hello
i always do this error message yeah
all right good poodle is a sporting dog
oh
sporting so sporting like that
yup life expectancy is about 14 14
very good and they are from germany oh
i as much as i like poodles i didn't
know that
now you know boom
okay there it is how's that look yup
looks good to me
so there we go we have now we have a
rest poodle api
uh so now we can jump to the code and
make it so that we can
check this out with http request wow my
favorite part
code so let's see we have a package.json
here
from uh previously uh that you had
written thank you for putting this
together roger
we have uh you put two dependencies in
here
yeah uh we're just gonna have express
and mysql so express is gonna serve as
http server
and in my sql will be used to you know
communicate with the sql database on the
back end
so it's as simple as that um and then we
also have that start line
that's what that's so that's what we're
going to use to start our
our app on the container once it's up in
uh
cloud run all right so i see here the
start
script mentions index.js so i guess
that's where the action is huh
yep that's where the magic happens so to
start out with
not a lot going on once again uh we're
initializing the
x the app with express and then we're
having it listen to port 8080
where it'll console log that the rest
api is listening to port 8080
and then it's going to reply to any http
request to the root with
a json object saying the status which is
barkbark ready to roll all right cool
uh let's run it see what happens
so uh-huh and there it is listening on
port 880 so we got
we got here in the code now yep and
we can get here yeah in a new window
just do a quick curl
localhost 8080 let's see what we get
at whoa look at that roger
looks great ready to roll but as you can
tell there are no poodles yet
so now let's add another app get
uh function that's going to return the
breed information that we specify in the
url
all right all right so you said we'll
have another app
yet here how about i start typing and
you can explain what's going on
yeah that's good sounds a good plan so
we're gonna have another app get
this time it's going to take the
variable for breed so we can attach our
breed to the end of the url and then
we're going to construct a query which
is going to be a standard sql query
select everything from breeds where the
name is equal to that breed variable
and then we're going to take that query
variable
and throw it into the pool.query method
and this is pretty much what's going to
relay our request to the sql database on
the back end
so if there are there there's no results
we want to let the user know that there
are no results so yep status
not found sounds a good way to let them
know
if there are results we want to respond
with a json object
with that result in it
all right so and i referenced the pool
variable up top
let's define that yeah and this is
pretty much
the pool of connections that our
application has to the sql database on
the back end
so we're going to put a few environment
variables that aren't defined yet well
they are defined but we'll show that in
a little bit
but this is pretty much the credentials
that it needs to
access the database that we just created
a little earlier
yeah and i like to usually let's see uh
process and oh yeah the instance
right okay i like to make this
uh there we go i like to make this
usually a global variable like this
so because it's global then it's reused
between invocations so if two
http calls hit the same cloudrun
instance that has served a request
before it can just reuse the pool
variable here and doesn't have to
create it anew right
let's scroll up a little bit let's make
sure let's take that v out oh dear
appetite
get function typo
that's checking it out real quick it
looks good to me if it looks good to you
all right i think yeah i think now we
can deploy this ah
and you sent me this handy dandy uh
deployment script so i'm just gonna run
it
and uh let's see here
uh and this deploy script might look
very it's gonna look very familiar
we've used it before uh it's gonna have
a little bit more information in it
because since we're connecting to a
cloud sql
instance it's gonna require a few uh
specific flags and
the environment variables that we
reference in the index.js code so those
are the environment variables up top
cloud project id the instance connection
name
the database credentials and those are
referenced
in the second command there cloud run
deploy the first one cloud build submit
is going to build our container and
submit it to the cloud the google
container registry
under our project yep
and here in the second one you said oh
right here
is where we're using all of those uh
variables like the database password
database user
yeah and it's important that we that we
include also the ads
cloud sql instances flag as well because
that's going to allow our container to
actually
use cloud sql backend yeah and it looks
like it uh
deployed down here it looks like it
finished so now let's
jump back to the cloud console let's
check out the
cloud builds page all right let's go to
uh
and let's see how that looks build
cloud build cloud build
succeeded 23 seconds ago so it looks all
good
uh if if we head over to the registry
container registry container registry we
should see
our container there it is
there it is the latest so one minute ago
so that's definitely it
let's tag that with the version 1.0 the
most dangerous version of any software
version 1.0 alright so here we are in
cloud run
we see our service here
and let's look at the revisions all
right
100 is going to the latest revision
that's looking good
let's click that url see what we got we
should
off the back get that ready to roll so
there it is ready to roll
okay looking good now let's check out
our poodle
okay the moment of truth poodle
okay there it is poodle sporting 14
germany
boom okay so that works excellent
so what's next uh i think now we want to
be able to add
more entries once again because again
having one entry is not very useful so
let's jump back to the code
it is kind of sad the database as much
as i like poodles
it's a little sad to only have portals
and we're back in index.js right yep
so we've had our two get functions
we've defined pool now what we're gonna
do is add a
post function so that's gonna look like
app.post start typing
here we go app.post you said yup and
we're just going to send a post request
to the root
uh the callback method is going to be
this asynchronous
function we're going to throw our data
into
this variable object
because we'll use it again in a second
so
rec body name those are that's just
taking the requests
um data because the request is going to
be a json object so it's going to take
that data out of that json object and
throw it into this data
variable name type life expectancy
origin
close that out and then we want to do
what we did before which
is make that query variable and now
construct our query which is another
simple sql query uh it's actually an
insert
query to insert breeds into breeds these
values
these question marks are going to be
used to
insert our values in the pool.query
function
right there in that second argument
and if there's an error we want to
respond with a json object
saying that there was an error so yep
status failure
and the reason is going to be the actual
error
if there is no error well we want to
reply
with the object that you just added to
our database and the status of success
so here's where we use that data
variable that we defined the beginning
of this
uh post function so that looks good to
me
yeah let me just eyeball it here make
sure
i made no typos this time
yeah looks looks about right looks about
right
and that's good enough for me so let's
deploy this once again with the
deploy.sa script
all right and there it goes
so roger uh i wonder here uh in
deploy.sh we're putting the password
here and sort of plain text in a file
it feels a little iffy what do you think
about this it doesn't feel good
you should never do that this is just
for demonstration purposes so
typically you'd want to use a more
secure way to
handle that like a secrets manager
all right that's part of the gcp right
yes
yeah okay cool uh but then other
variables that aren't as secret as
passwords they're fine to have as
environment variables right right that's
correct
okay so it looks like the deployment
finished um
we'll go back here um i guess we'll see
here
and we refresh we can check back on the
container registry page
oh right let's do it uh and let's tag
that second
upload as our version two
yeah let's do it i feel like i think
about jumping from one to two it seems
like a big
a big update we're yes being able to
write
yeah so here we have that one
we'll do version 2.0 we
are we are rolling
all right
cloud run barkbark api service
let's hit that url once again make sure
we didn't break the original
functionality that we had which was just
you know oh okay and 100 goes to the
latest yeah let's
make sure we didn't break it okay it's
just hitting the root there
still getting through poodle poodle
let's see if we broke it we didn't break
it let's try one more thing
remember we have an error message if we
don't have that dog so let's try uh
pug pug okay beloved pug
that's not my favorite kind of dog okay
we'll try it anyway
okay not found okay good so our error
works too so now let's jump to postman
and see if we can add pug to our
database
all right let's do it
so postman uh the audience might have
seen it
in our past episodes but this is pretty
much uh
a tool that we use to test uh rest apis
super handy for sending
posts uh and get requests to http
servers
yeah so i'll copy the uh yeah it makes
it a lot easier to send post requests as
you said i i copy
the i'm copying the url here and
top of the morning all right very nice
uh
here we go so there's the url let's see
can we make this bigger make that bigger
there's better
okay we are not going to post to slash
poodle we're just going to post
to the right and that was referenced in
the
code we're posting to the root yeah
we're going to send
this format of json
[Music]
yeah and let's see here it's a little
tricky you have to select
raw and then json for all the types to
work out correctly
okay so here as a i just copied the
poodle
now we're not going to paste the poodle
in again in the database
that would actually lead to an error
right because we have a constraint
it should give us an error and it won't
add the poodle but let's add pug
since you love pugs so much too p-u-g
pug is a companion oh not a sporting dog
okay surprise it's a companion dog
life expectancy is about 13 13
okay and where is that i don't know
where that's from
the pug is from china oh that's cool i
didn't know that
right so json object
yes send that off let's send that off
sending that request we should get a
success status
yes and then a copy of the data that we
just added
just to make triple sure let's hop into
our browser and go
to the slash pug url and see if we can
get our pug
data pug here
yes all right so now we've got two dogs
in our database so now
the it's it's a limitless opportunity to
add dog breeds to our database
and serve them via http requests
all serverless very cool
uh this was a fun programming project
yeah it was pretty easy too
surprisingly it's not a lot of work to
get this up and running yeah right
all right cool thank you everybody for
watching
this episode was created thanks to
feedback and questions from you
in the comments below so if there's
anything else you would like us
to program here please add it in the
comments or if you have any questions
about how we built this
see you later
[Music]